dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here anyone
who has tried building bridges over a
huge chasm realized that it is possibly
one of the most difficult and dangerous
things you could do on a family vacation
the basic construction elements for such
a bridge can be ropes cables and wires
and this kind of task is fundamentally
different from classical architectural
building problems here you don't need to
have any kind of scaffolding or to carry
building blocks that way a lot however
you have to know how to tie knots
therefore this is the kind of problem
you'll need flying machines for they can
fly anywhere they are nimble and their
disadvantage that they have a very
limited payload does not play a big role
here in this piece of work at the ETH
Zurich these machines can create some
crazy knots from single to multi round
turn hitches knobs elbows round turns
and multiple rope knobs and these you
have to be able to create in a
collaborative manner because each
individual flying machine will hold one
rope therefore they have to pass through
given control points at a strictly given
time and a target velocity these little
guys also have to know the exact amount
of force they need to exert on the
structure to move into a desirable
target position even deploying the rope
is not that trivial the machine is
equipped with a roller to do so but the
friction of this roller can be changed
at any time according to the Rope
releasing direction to unroll it
properly you also have to face the
correct direction as well and these
structures are not just toys the
resulting bridges are resilient enough
for humans to use this work is a great
example to show that the technology of
today is improving at an incredible pace
if we can solve difficult collaborative
control problems such as this one just
think about the possibilities what an
exciting time it is to be alive we have
gotten lots of shares for the series on
social media I'm trying to send a short
thank you message for every single one
of you I'm trying my best and don't
forget every single share helps
spreading the word for the series
immensely thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time